[Music]
i'm john dj
desjardins visual effects supervisor for
zack snyder's justice league
i'm gonna try to talk about every major
superpower on the movie
first up we're gonna talk about superman
heat vision's kind of like something
between a flame thrower and a laser
right it has a certain character to the
edge of it which is
a little bit like a a jagged flamey kind
of thing
that has a direction to it and a
frequency to it
when we were working on man of steel we
made sure there was a difference between
superman's heat vision
and zod superman probably doesn't feel
that much pain anyway but it shouldn't
look like it's
the easiest thing to do like that's why
he doesn't do it all the time
you know we don't even know if he can
see when he does it but that's why it's
always like he does it and it's kind of
like
ah you know he turns it off and it's
like okay where are we
in man of steel when he's a little kid
that's when he first gets it
we didn't want to ever have a fall off
really because a lot of times in the
other movies even the
richard donner movie it's it's always
kind of weird because it's like a
little spotlight on something you know
it's like here's the inside of a safe
here's the
you know the inside of this box or
something and we just figured it was one
of those
nightmarish powers where if you turn it
on you see everything like that you know
and and that was
how we did that you know we we shoot a
play we always survey
everything we always light our
everything we always do an extensive
you know enviro camera texture shoot and
hand that over to in this case it was
scanline that ended up doing that
and yeah it was them just looking at
everything in the scene and
getting all the insides modeled out and
you know bring it out to various degrees
in the composite
[Music]
zach had this really interesting rule
you know or thing that he did
when he first flies he's like doing
these super jumps in man of steel
he faces the sun and realizes this is
something that comes from inside him
and he kneels down and you see the snow
start to go around
and there is a bit of that in justice
league when he puts on the black suit
and comes out you see him kneel down
and the debris and stuff starts going
and then he just goes
and zach would say i kind of want to put
some float into them like do we hang
them from wires do we put them on a
belly pan
do we put them in a tuning fork the
short answer is we did all of those
things
and we knew what we could do to
like have him take off from just
standing there and become cg
all henry cavill had to do is make a
move like
i'm going
[Music]
i think our philosophy never really
changed from man of steel when it came
to superman super strength he can really
wield that stuff around as quickly as he
wants and so
anytime he had to pick up anything it
was usually some kind of green
foam you know lightweight buck that we
use to get his handholds right i think
it was in bbs where he picks up a part
of a spacecraft same kind of thing
all these characters have some kind of
super strength but they have
slight differences and so there were a
lot of conversations about
who do we think is stronger you know is
it wonder woman or is it superman i
think
superman probably with raw brute
strength is
stronger than she is but remember she is
magical
now i'm going to talk about wonder
woman's powers
in our version it only lights up
when it encircles an organic
or like a living thing really evident in
zack's justice league where
she actually lassos catwalk to as she
shoots out after the pair of demons just
to kind of like change her trajectory
and help her land on the catwalk but it
doesn't light up because it's an
inorganic
you know structure we had a lot of
experience with leds and
you know we all worked on watchmen
together so dr manhattan
led suit you know we knew that okay
let's get a strip of leds
that we could put into a robe the first
thing that happened with that was it
broke
all the time so we realized we only use
it to light her up
or light the person up that it's
surrounding
anything in between doesn't matter so we
put bungees in the middle
that kept it from breaking so much but
that's kind of how we did that
so the funny thing about that is we
always called it the boosh
that's that's what we call it zach and
michael wilkinson designed them they're
not braces they're gauntlets
because she's a warrior you know it's
like that's what you had we decided that
she's gotta fight she's gonna fight
against doomsday and all this stuff so
we need
something that she can do you know
and that's where that came from it
literally came from
the necessity of the fight yeah we all
love the boosh
next up flash
[Music]
trying to dissect how to do flash was i
think one of our more
interesting problems on the movie we had
a couple rules for all this kind of fast
travel
one main rule with flash was we don't
ever want to see him run
like this we don't ever want to see that
so that's why almost like six million
dollar man the faster he runs
it's almost like the slower he gets you
see him
rev up in slow motion with the slow
motion lightning and then
boom he's gone if you see him in real
time you can't even see him run
you know he's just gone they really just
vanish
huh oh that's rude
and then when you start running with him
he may look fairly normal but it's
generally 48 frames a second but the
exterior is whipping by
right we always pretended like we're
trying to photograph him but we can
never pick
the right frame rate to really get him
so yeah we all
start to really almost fly
in the junction rescue scene where barry
allen is rescuing iris
you know from this car accident we came
up with a couple of rules one was
if everything else in the world when
you're in flash time with him looks like
it's at 600 frames per second or more
barry allen's able to move at a
different frame rate but
not quite 24 frames per second normal
we usually shot them at 48 frames per
second just to give them a little float
when we knew we have to get into a green
screen stage
and start doing everything from there
we're like okay we need to make that
environment in cg
we need to make the crash in cg and
keirsey is going to have to be on some
kind of rig
to float her that's pretty controllable
and she's going to have to act frozen
if she moves we're going to have to
stabilize her and post and so if you
look at the footage it's pretty
interesting because first she's in her
costume
on a kuka arm motion control rig being
floated
up while ezra looks up at her you pull
their hair back
and then you make cg hair that can
dovetail into their real hairline
and make it float the way you need to
float and as ezreal looked like he was
just about to touch her she would start
to roll
and he would just kind of pretend to
guide her down without touching her too
much
this is another rule with the flash you
can't grab someone and save them
if those she's on the ground and her
clothes kind of get flowy and her hair
gets flowy
and then once she's down on the ground
then we kind of go into real time
the time travel was always a part of the
end of the movie everyone in the justice
league has a particular thing they have
to do in the fight at the end
flash's main job is to build up a charge
and give it to cyborg to be able to do
what he needs to do i can conduct a
significant electrical current i
i might be able to wake the box but
weird things happen
as i get close to speed of light the
time travel thing is fun because
zack was very clear he wanted the mother
boxes to
merge the effect would essentially raise
the planet just erase everything
and he wanted it to be a void like a
like just a void with a quasar at the
origin
and it would become very beautifully
cosmic
and the origin of that would come with
each of flash's footsteps
he said i want like a big bang to come
out of each footstep
and that starts to repopulate the void
which when you look behind him you
realize he's actually
like a tidal wave pulling and you have
to remember how much time he's actually
pulling
six seconds of time back is what he's
doing it's not much
but it's huge it's like the hugest thing
ever
[Music]
yeah we all know batman's power is he's
rich
what are your superpowers again i'm rich
and he has a lot of gadget our version
of batman and the gadgets
is probably a little bit different zach
really wanted to model
our batman on frank miller's dark knight
returns the batmobile is
still beefy and it's got some bat
properties to it
he's got the grapple gun which he uses
in different ways
in justice league we extend the powers a
little bit or the gadgets a little bit
so that he has a gauntlet
you know you could see alfred shoot one
of the kryptonian guns which i thought
was pretty fun because we kept those
from man of steel
and same effect and everything well we
see it get used to absorb
parademon gunfire ultimately it's gonna
save his life
in his rematch against superman i guess
in the park battle
aquaman whose strength we think comes
from the fact that
he can withstand you know crazy
underwater pressures that no human being
can
he's half human half atlantean so he can
he can breathe underwater and he is
really strong from being able to be
underwater
some kind of hydrokinesis that trident
is a way for him to channel his
hydrokinesis and that's what he's doing
when he tries to hold the water back you
know you just can't
do it indefinitely and i would also
think too that the hydrokinesis is the
other thing that helps
he and other atlanteans swim underwater
even when you look at the first time you
see him in bvs
when he kind of attacks the underwater
camera and then
speeds off he's just flying underwater
that's what we think they do
we think that they manipulate like some
kind of underwater slipstream
we had some really early conversations
where zack's like i don't think
atlanteans can talk underwater and so
that's where the air bubble
rule came from we figured if they have
hydrokinesis they can open up an air
bubble if they want to have a long
conversation
i like it it's quiet
next up cyborg
[Music]
i think maybe his biggest power is
manipulation of data
you know and his control over the
virtual world he can fly
and he has certain weapons that can come
out of his body
i feel like we don't really know what
all those are but we tried to represent
the most popular ones
you know especially with the sonic
cannon relax alfred don't take it from
here
let's put ray in a performance capture
outfit make sure he's got
all the interactive light elements that
we need so he's got an eye
it's gonna light up his face and anybody
close to him he's got a chest piece that
represents the energy in his chest
gonna light him up here it's gonna light
up anybody standing close like when he
talks to diana and so forth
that's it you know he basically lived
with that for months
steppenwolf
this was a big ticket item he's a space
faring being
so he he can he can jump a lot i guess i
guess maybe earth's gravity is nothing
for him so he can jump around
very freely he doesn't fly but he does
have the electro axe
[Music]
these characters are all based on jack
kirby's fourth world characters which
are just
lsd psychedelic trippy as hell you got
to have an electro axe
we wanted him to use it it's got
lightning to it it
it's it's pretty r-rated in this version
he does
hack people to pieces yeah that's that's
steppenwolf
that's good
it was always adaptive armor which is
why it has all the little
we call them blades you know it's made
of all these little blades and they all
need to animate
and you almost call it mood armor in
some ways you know it's when it's docile
it kind of looks
kind of low-key although it has a little
flutter to it you know
and then when he's mad it's super spiky
you know which is kind of fun
but we always loved it we always loved
it and rich cetrone
played steppenwolf he had a performance
capture suit on
and the electro axe was
i don't think it was it must have been
like a scaled version for him
and it had a bunch of leds along the
blade
area which is where most of the energy
would come from like that scene where he
like
comes down on superman henry could stand
there and it would glow you know would
light him correctly so we're really
happy to
finally be able to execute it i'm real
happy with it in the movie
a mega beam kills volkow and it was our
one
moment to do it because we always wanted
to do the omega beams the mega beams
again
jack kirby fourth world trippy lsd stuff
so
that was fun yeah jaggy beams jaggy
beams
green lantern power ring he's an ancient
green lantern
you know 15 000 20 000 years ago wanted
his power to be raw
not have a construct to it beans
beams are cool
martian man hunter i'll be in touch
[Music]
marcia matt hunter shape-shifting old
conversation with zach i always thought
it'd be cool for him to be swanwick put
in the scene where he's martha
really hard to do because we couldn't do
any kind of capture on anybody to do
this we did shoot
harry lennox remotely because it was
covet it is coveted times and it was
coveted times
and we had video of his face delivering
these lines that zach had for him
but the entire creation was done
remotely from home
and animated by a very good team of
animators at scanline
martian manhunter we always love him by
the way he's one of the mainstays of
justice league so
we wanted to really bring him into it by
the end of the movie
so i think that's every major superpower
in zack snyder's justice league
but i probably left something out so i
apologize we ended up doing something on
2700 shots you know in about seven
months
and again it wasn't actually the
execution of the work the simplest shots
were the ones to start from scratch
the hardest ones were everything else
where something had been done
to varying degrees when i'm working with
zach i always do a director's cut
every time